♪
>> Will: IT JOE BIDEN CHALLENGE
HIS FELLOW AMERICANS TO A
NUCLEAR ARMS RACE?
>> WHAT'S HAPPENED IS THAT THERE
NEVER BEEN -- IF YOU WANT --
THINK YOU NEED TO HAVE WEAPONS
TO TAKE ON THE GOVERNMENT.
YOU NEED F-15s AND MAYBE SOME
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> Will: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
KNOW THIS BUT PEOPLE ARE
RESPONDING.
AMERICANS ARE RUSHING THOUGHT
RECORD NUMBERS TO BUY F-15s
AND NUKES TO FIGHT OFF THE
GOVERNMENT.
NOT REALLY, YOU SEE, THAT
HEADLINE WAS A JOKE FROM THE
SATIRICAL WEBSITE THE BABYLON
BEE.
USES COMEDY TO HELP RAISE
CONCERNS OVER REAL ISSUES LIKE
IN THIS INSTANCE THE PRESIDENT
POINTING OUT THAT HE IS
EFFECTIVELY THREATENING
AMERICANS WITH NUCLEAR WAR,
AGAIN MAYBE NOT REALLY.
JOINING ME NOW THE MAN BEHIND
THIS WEBSITE CEO OF THE BABYLON
BEE SETH DILLON.
SETH, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HEADLINE
HERE IS THAT JOE BIDEN IS IN AN
ARMS RACE WITH WE, HIS FELLOW
AMERICANS OR BAD AT HISTORY.
I THINK THE TALIBAN JUST FOUGHT
OVER A NUCLEAR POWER FOR 20
YEARS WITH GUNS.
WELL, WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
BELIEVE IS THAT A GROUP OF
UNARMED -- HUGE UNARMED GROUP OF
TRUMP SUPPORTERS STORMED OF THE
CAPITOL BUILDING AND ABOUT TO
TOPPLE THE GOVERNMENT.
APPARENTLY THAT WAS POSSIBLE
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO.
>> Will: RIGHT.
>> NOW WE NEED JETS AND NUKES.
>> Will: UNARMED PEOPLE ALMOST
TOPPLED DEMOCRACY BY TOPPLING
CAPITOL ON JANUARY THE 6TH.
YOU GUYS HAD A AWESOME HEADLINE
AT THE BABYLON BEE.
THIS IS OP-ED WRITTEN BY KING
GEORGE.
YOU WILL NEVER BEAT A TYRANNICAL
GOVERNMENT WITH JUST GUNS.
THIS IS THE MESSAGING YOU WOULD
GIVE TO PEOPLE IF YOU WANTED
ENCOURAGE THEM TO BUY MORE GUNS
AND BIGGER GUNS.
>> Will: THAT'S RIGHT.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND THERE AT THE
BABYLON BEE I WANT TO GIVE GOAT
A MORE SERIOUS ISSUE WITH YOU
HERE IN A MOMENT.
YOU A NEW DOCUMENTARY OUT AS
WELL.
HAVE YOU FOUND THE LATEST TREND
IN TRANSSPORTS IT'S
MOTORCYCLISTst WHO IDENTIFY AS
BICYCLE LISTS.
WATCH.
>> I HAVE ALWAYS KNOWN THAT
SOMETHING ABOUT ME WAS
DIFFERENT.
THERE WAS SOMETHING WRONG AFTER
A LOT OF THOUGHT AND REFLECTION
I FINALLY REALIZED THAT MY LIFE
AS A MOTORCYCLIST WAS A LIE.
I WAS A BICYCLIST.
JOINING THE RACE IS NORM
HICKHAM.
>> WAIT.
I THOUGHT HE RACED MOTORCYCLES.
I NEVER FELT BETTER.
>> FREE TO BE MY TRUE SELF.
LIVE MY TRUE JUST BE ME.
>> Will: I DON'T KNOW IF THE
CULTURE HAS MOVED YOUR WAY OR
YOU JUST HIRED ALL THE TALENT
AWAY BUT SOMEHOW YOU ARE IN A
BETTER POSITION THAN ANY OTHER
COMEEFD DICK ORGANIZATION RIGHT
NOW TO POINT OUT THE ABSURDITY
OF OUR CULTURE.
>> WELL, THIS IS THE THING.
IN THIS CASE WE ARE SPEAK TRUTH
TO POWER.
THIS STUFF IS COMING FROM THE
TOP DOWN.
THESE ARE THE MOST POWERFUL
PEOPLE IN GOVERNMENT AND
CORPORATIONS.
THIS PROGRESSIVE IDEOLOGY AND
THESE PROGRESSIVE VALUES ARE
BEING IMPOSED ON US ALL THE WAY
FROM THE TOP.
SO WE SEE THIS AS SPEAKING TRUTH
TO POWER.
BUT, A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
SUGGESTING THAT THESE JOKES ARE
PUNCHING DOWN AND I HAVE A HARD
TIME GRAPPLING WITH THAT AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEY MEAN BY
THAT.  THAT'S ONE OF THE NEW
LINES OF ATTACKS AGAINST US.
AT FIRST IT WAS WE'RE SPREADING
MISINFORMATION.
NOW WE ARE PUNCH BEING DOWN AT
PEOPLE WE SHOULDN'T BE
ATTACKING.
THAT'S A WAY OF THEM PROTECTING
THEIR SACRED COWS AND ALSO
PRETTY CONDESCEND THAWING
SHOULDN'T JOKE ABOUT CERTAIN
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY ARE BENEATH
YOU.
>> Will: THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
TRIED TO HAVE YOU PUSHED OFF OF
FACEBOOK AND OTHER PLACES UNDER
THE GUISE OF MISINFORMATION.
BABYLON SUED.
YOU WERE QUICKLY REINSTATED
BECAUSE YOU ARE SATIRE AND
COMEDY.
ONE LAST POINT OUT OF PERSONAL
CURIOSITY, SETH.
SO A FEW YEARS AGO PEOPLE SAID
CONSERVATIVES COULDN'T BE FUNNY.
THERE WAS NO SOURCE OF
CONSERVATIVE HUMOR AND MAYBE
THEY WERE RIGHT THERE WASN'T A
BIG CULTURAL POCKET FOR THAT.
WHAT'S CHACKETD CHANGED?
I MEAN ONE THING I NOTICED THAT
CHANGED PEOPLE WHO USED TO BE
FUNNY BY THE WAY WHO WERE ALL ON
THE LEFT ARE NOT FUNNY ANYMORE.
SO WHAT'S CHANGED?
>> YEAH.
THEY DID A LOT OF THE CHANGING.
I MEAN, THEY STARTED MAKING ALL
THESE THINGS OFF LIMIT THAT YOU
CAN'T JOKE ABOUT FOR ONE THING.
SO THEY BEGAN TO CENSOR
THEMSELVES AND THEY BEGAN TO TRY
TO CENSOR OTHER PEOPLE.
SO WHEN YOU START TO HAVE THIS
CULTURE AND CLIMATE WHERE PEOPLE
LIKE JERRY SEINFELD ARE AVOIDING
DOING COMEDY SHOWS ON COLLEGE
PUS CAMPUSES BECAUSE EVERYBODY
WANTS A SAFE SPACE AND DOESN'T
WANT TO BE OFFENDED THEY ARE
CHANGING THE LANDSCAPE.
THEY ARE HAVING A HARD TIME
BEING FUNNY DANCING AROUND THE
ISSUES THEY WANT TO AVOID.
THAT OPPORTUNITY POLITICALLY
INCORRECT JOKES YOU ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO MAKE.
THEY OPENED UP A HUGE GATEWAY
FOR PEOPLE TO COME AND TAKE SOME
OF THAT MARKET SHARE.
>> Will: PEOPLE HAVE BABYLON
BELAYED MORE ENGAGEMENTS THAN
THE ONION.
CHECK OUT THEIR SITE.
YOU ARE MISSING OUT.
I PROMISE YOU IF YOU ARE NOT